the impact of screens on sleep you know
people are exposing their eyes to this
stream of photons from these objects
that basically tells your brain
stay awake it's not time to go to sleep
yet so it's 10 p.m. it's 11 p.m. it's 12
p.m. you're checking for email you're
looking for text you're doing all these
things that light beams in you it tells
your brain don't secrete melatonin yet
it's not time for sleep and you're up at
12:30 over 1 you're checking some
workers are up after all why shouldn't
you check now you go to bed at 1:00 you
wake up at 6 to get ready for work
that's 5 hours of sleep we now know that
what sleep is likely doing is allowing
your active neurons to rest which is
fine but more than that the supportive
cells called glial cells are now
cleaning up the toxins that the neurons
produce and if you don't get from 7 to 9
hours of sleep you just get 5 the toxins
remain there for over 95% of people
there are small percent of people are
genetically different they don't need
that much sleep but for the vast
majority of us we need 7 to 9 hours of
sleep so even though it's like a badge
of courage I only have three hours of
sleep last night I'm not working today
it makes your attention falter your
memory is impaired your ability to think
through problems is challenged your
insulin even that helps regulate your
metabolism is turned upside down so
you're more likely to gain weight from
what you eat and eat more and then if
that weren't enough it's actually toxic
to the connections in your cells so in
your brain so what you want to do is
prioritize sleep shut off your screens
let's say by 9 p.m.
give yourself an hour at least before
you're going to bed and keep those
screens off it's a serious serious
problem for everyone and we can do
something about it by actually actively
deciding that's
we're going to do is take care of this
aspect of the digital domain